they won't develop a mask in physique or
learn combat skills they just
won't I had this guy who was an incel
sends me a email I think he wanted to do
a uh a sponsored request so if you don't
watch the entrepreneurs and cars Channel
you should go subscribe to it uh people
can sponsor videos over there and ask me
to respond to whatever it is that
they're stuck on
okay and I usually end up reading you
know whatever it is that they're stuck
on takes 20 25 minutes get feedback
boom I said to this guy instead of me
reading what you're writing here why
don't you come on the show and let's go
back and forth because this is going to
take a little bit of time right like
when I do private consults like I'm
dealing with high net worth individuals
my rate is not cheap it's expensive you
can book me online at rcooper.com
about two or 3 months
ago and the guy's like basically I'm a
really nice guy he sounded like a nice
guy and women don't want anything to do
with me I just don't have any success
right you know with the gals and it's
like you know you ask him some questions
well what do you do for a living well
doesn't really do much he's not
influential he's not C captivating he
doesn't have um a good social network
doesn't have any skills he's way
underweight I think he was 130 lbs 5
foot six or seven six you know wasn't
super tall but way way underweight right
like like my chick's 5 foot 8 130 lbs
you know she's fit she's got a little
bit of muscle on her but she's mostly
you like a fit chick sort of thing and
it's like dude you weigh less than a
chick like why don't you go to a gym
well you know I don't know like maybe I
will sort of thing why aren't you at a
dojo learning in Combat Sports like
learn how to throw hands and fight you
know like you know I was talking this
other kid a couple weeks ago he had me
as an interview on his channel uh his
name's Tyson hawkley seems like um a
good upand comom 16 years old right
finds me on Twitter says hey man young
young man I want to have you on my
podcast ask you some questions sure no
problem talk about a few uh Concepts and
ideas get to Combat Sports yeah my mom
doesn't really want me to fight because
you know she thinks I'm going to get
hurt I'm going to break my face it's
like this is where we are right like you
know helicopter parenting is like pfy
children to the point where they're not
allowed to learn fundamental skills of
life like combat like how to throw hands
what happens if the [__] hits the fan
what are you gonna [__] do right what
are you g to do nothing is what you're
going to do you're going to be one of
those people that are like well I'm
afraid of guns and I never want to want
my kids to learn how to fight so I don't
want them to get injured or hurt their
noses so they have to stay inside and
you know like in a bubble the [__] hits
a fan people that have the means that
have the ability to wield violence will
be going around taking [__] from you is
what's going to
happen nobody likes a Meek
man my advice is go anyway [__] what
your parents think go learn how to
fight so back to the insult didn't want
to lift weights didn't want to go to the
gym didn't want to learn how to fight
it's like bro how am I supposed to
[__] help you if you're not willing
to help yourself you won't even do the
Basics 130 pound I would be embarrassed
to be an adult male at 130 PBS okay
pocket Hercules the guy that I've talked
about before buddy that I grew up with
in my 20s and 30s we used to live
together he was 5'5 he was about 165 lbs
okay I don't give a [__] 130 lbs at 56
5'7 whatever it was is embarrassing I
would be embarrassed to be that light to
walk around I I remember as a
14 15 16 like when you go through the
growth spurts and you're just shooting
up like a freaking
rocket and uh you know sometimes you
wake up and you're sore because your
bones have grown overnight like that's
you know that's what it's like and like
weighing in at 140 lbs or something like
that I mean I'm I'm a pretty decent size
now I'm 6'2 215 lbs or so but there was
a time when I was like you know over 6
foot and I was light I was I was
embarrassed I was embar like I used to
even in the time I would wear big
sweaters to try to like hide you know
how thin I was and I was doing push-ups
and I was doing pull-ups and I was doing
the curls and I was reading like you
know I was I was reading about how to
build muscle I didn't want to be skinny
you know I I saw icons like Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Conan the Barbarian I
thought to myself that's what I want to
look like but people don't do that today
guys are just like yeah you know why
don't girls like me it's like bro you're
130 lb girls are bigger than like the
average chick in North America is
probably 180 lb 100 I think let me just
look it up real quick I think the
average weight of a western woman it's
been published somewhere what's the
average weight of a
western I think it's 160 180 pounds it's
[__] ridiculous here it is the
average woman aged 20 years and above
weigh
17.8 pounds no wonder chicks aren't
looking at you they're like outweighing
You by a huge
margin because it's hard to lift weights
because it's hard to get punched yeah
it's hard anything worthwhile in life is
going to be
hard I used to have a part-time job when
I was in high school nursery as a garden
center it's a pretty cool place to work
out work at actually because there was a
lot of young attractive women in
Cashiers and the you know like the
Garden Center and the the crafts like
there's a lot of checks there so it was
a good place to be social it was a good
place you know to develop some strength
and some skills because a lot of [__]
you had to pick up was heavy as as hell
like four four cubic feet of Peete Moss
5 foot park benches all these things
that we had to lug out from the back to
customers cars and you're in the sun
sweating a lot of the time you know the
summer time it was actually a pretty
decent job you know for a
teenager um back to the part-time part I
never my dad would never give me a ride
to work he'd be like ride your bike walk
I don't give a [__] take the bus you
know you figure it out right I didn't
have access to a car my younger brothers
got the car when they were teenagers I
didn't get [__] so I'd be sitting at the
bus
stop you know 15 years old okay and I'm
looking at the cars going by and my
favorite car at the time uh was an irck
convertible it was a Chevy Camaro they
made him from
85 to 1990 was a body style that I liked
okay wasn't powerful car 5 liter T Port
injected engine maybe 200 200 220
horsepower car but they look [__]
cool I remember sitting there cuz you
wouldn't see a lot of exotic cars back
then you wouldn't see Ferraris and
Lambos and [__] like that this was the
exotic car to a 15-year-old like me at
the time and I'm like that seemed like
so Out Of Reach they were probably 2530
you know I would go home and I would
look it up right or I would walk into
the deal be like how much is this car
right it was like you know 25 $35,000
like somewhere in that range you know
depending on how you loaded it and it's
like that seems so Out Of Reach when
you're making $22.75 an hour right like
how the [__] do you turn
$2.75 an hour 25 to$ 35,000 so you can
have the car you want I figured it out I
figured it out cuz I bought the car like
five six years later you know when I was
like 2021 I figured it out right like
this is what guys do I've said this many
many times you know people ask me all
the time like what's the most most
important skill you got to have as as an
entrepreneur yeah the most important
skill you got to have is problem solving
skills like solving problems that you're
dealing with and guys would rather be
like well women are [__] so I'm not
going to do
anything I'm going to just go to my room
and stay there instead fine you know
don't call in on my shows and ask stupid
[__] questions
though all right we covered masculine
physique Combat
Sports and my dudes that go to the gym I
I salute you I see you guys you know
working out picking up heavy [__]
putting down working on your physique
eating the calories you know drinking
the liquids doing everything that you
need to do to put on the size and the
mass and create the Optics of
masculinity it's not
hard it really isn't it's not difficult
it's just putting in the Reps in the
time eating good food moving more
there's a couple of guys that I follow
on social media that uh deal with
fitness and health I don't need help
with fitness and health but I'm but I'm
interested in the engagement
conversations they have and I noticed
there's a few guys dialoguing back and
forth about this um peptide
semaglutide OIC or whatever the hell
it's called it's that new one um I
bought some stock in Eli ly months ago
on the recommendation of a friend that
deals in that space and you know it's
done really well but it it's that
company that basically gives you that
week weekly injection it's a a pen you
don't even have to know how to [__]
inject it's so basic a [__] Monkey
could do it where they could just stick
it in and it's like boom oh they got the
injection right like they' like they've
made it that simple they don't even have
to learn how to pull it out of a syringe
and clean or back fill another syringe
they made it so simple [__] M okay I
got my shot right they these people just
want to keep eating [__] but take the
shot so they can keep eating [__] I'm
like are you [__] kidding me these
are the like this is what these guys in
that space are dealing with like that's
what their customers are they want to
keep eating [__] their pizzas their hot
dogs their Frozen Foods their microwave
dinners their McDonald's drive-thru
[__] they want to keep eating that
and then take a shot and not be fat it's
like this is your competition this is
this is the vast majority of males out
there today are the people that you're
generally competing with I really hope
you guys enjoy that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out